hello george
hey how you doing i'm doing fine today
i'm talking to george tremblay he's a
very interesting man he's into asian
languages and i think the first one he
learned was japanese and today i want to
talk about how to learn japanese with
george
remember if uh if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
uh click on the bell for notifications
uh if you follow me on spotify or apple
podcast or any other podcast source
leave a review much appreciated george
george
las vegas
where we go to make money on the slot
machine
but george speaks japanese korean and
other languages i would like to first of
all ask george how what do you think
what is the best way to learn japanese
it's a big question but i think the
first question that i always think about
when i think if someone wants to learn a
language
i think
are they interested in the country you
know are they interested in the culture
is there something that fascinates them
about it that would keep driving them
because as you know
learning a language isn't just something
you go oh i'm going to learn a language
and a month later you have the language
there's a lot of a lot of effort that
has to go into it i think
so if if for example you like j-pop
music you watch you listen to music if
you like
uh some sort of drama in japanese or
some sort of game that's japanese that
you could get your hand on the japanese
version i think a good thing to do is
kind of follow your hobby
um
but if you're talking about of course if
you're talking obviously i teach
japanese right so i'm speaking in
general terms right now but let's say
you decide okay i want to learn japanese
so in my in my way of learning i did the
same thing with korean
uh i was in a classroom in japan and i
went to classes in korea actually but
you don't have to do that nowadays
because the internet provides so much
access to korean teachers or japanese
teachers that you know i would say hey
get a japanese teacher find a channel on
youtube find some tools that are like uh
link for example find some tools that
will help you learn and just bust
through
the basic grammar i really believe you
should go through the basic grammar as
fast as you can
and learn the writing system that would
be the step one i would say okay a
couple of things first of all
you have learned japanese to a high
degree of proficiency and korean what
was your motivation you said get
motivated by something so what motivated
you to learn japanese
well japanese was
i mean it's the same for japanese and
korean for me but you know uh the start
of japanese was
i was 12 and my father was a military
contractor his company had a contract
with the military and that led us to be
up in japan in 1985
so i was 12 i was in sixth grade on the
military air base and
one of the classes that i was required
to take was japanese so that got me
started and i think
it wasn't until maybe about the next
year or after that when i started
thinking about girls and japanese girls
to me were attractive so i just was
motivated by that initially
and then the continued motivation for me
was uh i started listening to j-pop like
i said and of course i had access to a
lot of fun japanese tv every week i was
watching the japanese top 10 to see the
artists that i love i learned the lyrics
of the music i joined the fan club i
went to the concerts i did all of that i
was i was a weeb i don't know if you
know that term before weebs were
probably a thing okay i just really
loved everything japan at the time now
let's suppose that you're not 12 or 15
and you're not chasing japanese girls
and you're not into j-pop
let's say that you're 30 or 25.
obviously something has to motivate you
so it could be anime it could be any
number of things how about the learning
methodology you know
my experience has been that the grammar
if you just get it up front it's very
difficult to relate it to anything until
you have enough exposure to the language
i absolutely agree right uh so
this is the problem i think
um that i see a lot of people not with
grammar and per se i see a lot of people
when they start learning japanese they
immediately want to jump into learning
kanji for example so
and it's easy to start learning kanji
and then have that as your badge right
like i know 400 kanji i now know 500
kanji but in the end you don't know
really how to use that kanji you just
you're it's i always like to call it a
parlor trick it's something you can brag
about and i think even a lot of uh times
classes or teachers sometimes if they
get a student that goes that direction
they let them go that direction because
it's an easy way to grade them to say
hey oh look my student made this
progress but really
uh
that's a mistake i believe that you you
know like you said you can learn you
could learn you can get up to jlpt level
in grammar the japanese language
proficiency test level one and maybe not
even know how to have great conversation
so what i always think is you
learn grammar you learn a grammar point
and then you try to find a way to use it
if you don't use it you're going to lose
it and you don't want to learn above
what you really are capable of doing
this is what i always believe like
when for example when i was learning
korean
i would i went to korea
and i took a group class in the morning
and i took a private class after that or
sometimes i flipped it
and then whatever i learned that day i
would kind of keep in my head and that
night i would go out to what they have
these language meetups that you can do
in korea where people get together
they're learning english and korean and
japanese and german it's actually really
fascinating
and i would go to those and i would just
in my mind i would think i'm going to
use this grammar the minute you use a
grammar
you you build this a bigger connection
in your brain and it becomes more
natural now
you know
i don't recommend that when you're doing
something like that if you learn a new
grammar never preface it don't say hey
uh can i test this new grammar with you
because then that the the
native speaker is going to be on the
outlook what i like to do is use the
grammar
see what happens
sometimes sometimes especially in korean
i got you know i would learn a grammar
not fully understand the implication of
that grammar and get a huge laugh
and now i don't know exactly why it's
funny but now i know okay there's
something about that that makes it funny
so the next time i do it again and i
start building an understanding of why
people are laughing at that particular
grammar right right um but without that
experience yeah you could blindly
say things that are rude for example uh
i'm sorry i'm just going to barrel
through one more
my
video editor mike
he's learning japanese and he was saying
a complicated sentence to me the other
day
and he used nante in japanese in a
really weird way and it sounded like he
said something like uh erico
which which could mean
you know oh man i can't believe you can
actually make delicious cooking right
but he wasn't trying to say that he
didn't understand the implications of
what nante does so without using that
grammar
you know now the first time he uses it
he might have made that mistake but he
would have learned right away that
wasn't good to do so using it absolutely
right away is the best thing to do don't
use words that you're not going to use
don't learn kanji you know i'm a big fan
of just in time learning
after you get the basics down just just
in time learning for those things right
interesting i mean everyone has a
different approach in my case i had
learned chinese beforehand so i had the
kanji
uh so that was not an issue
i tend to favor as you know a lot more
input before i
speak unless i'm there like in your
situation you were in japan you're in
korea you have all kinds of opportunity
to use the language i guess
one of the messages there is that
there's
many different roads that are going to
take us to success in in language
absolutely uh and it depends on your
circumstance
but uh so you you were totally into
japanese learning and then all of a
sudden you got interested in korean why
did you get interested in korea
can i go back just a second though and
talk about the input so
yeah input is something i highly
recommend a lot
um one of the things that so i have the
video series on youtube and one thing i
constantly recommend to people is
is for them to listen to japanese radio
right
find a good podcast or a radio but it
can't be one i firmly believe it
shouldn't be one that's designed for
students of japanese or designed for
students in korean
i want full-blown
full-speed
fully actuated korean or japanese so
that your brain can hear things
um that that you're not going to hear in
a classroom because it's in a sense when
you're learning in a classroom it's fun
and all but it's classroom japanese it's
it's a subset of japanese and you know
even me you know before i went to korea
i learned in a with a meetup group here
so i had learned those kind of
what's what i'm looking for like really
clean sentences right uh that have no
advanced grammar because it's a lower
level sentence and it's not set in a way
with any um's or odds you know but then
you go to korea and or you go to japan
and all of a sudden you're in a
convenience store and they say something
super basic back to you but you've never
heard it you've never been exposed to it
but if you had been watching dramas or
listening to people speak your brain
would have picked up things i did it
with chinese too
the thing is um
you know podcast now you mentioned
something
i've had trouble finding good podcasts
in korean and japanese
oh uh i can recommend something yeah i
think our my listeners would be very
interested in getting lists of good and
then i can give you two right now if
you'd like sure well uh yeah yeah i'll
put them in the description box okay
and i'll say it in a way that it's easy
to find so
one is a super casual one if you look up
uh the the full japanese name is
something like uh uh konkatsu styristo
judy but if you look up j-u-r-i j you
are a podcast app and she also has a
youtube channel she's a fairly minor one
right but the topics that she talks
about are very interesting it's about
it's people that want to get married
right and they're they're they're asking
dating questions to her so she will
receive a question from a from a guy
and then she'll read the question then
answer it but she's speaking
clearly
and on an interesting lower level topic
because it's
about relationships right so that's
that's one that's that's short and as
you say those kinds of things have
resonance whereas what you get in the
classroom has no resonance the narrator
is bored the content is uninteresting
whereas so j-u-r-i okay that's what yep
j-u-r and j-u-r-i and the second one
that i i love for the quality of sound
and the fact that it's really high level
but yet they're still speaking in a
normal speaking tone it's cozy up
c-o-z-y up the full name of the show is
something like
something news kojiapu in katakana uh
but but that one is excellent because
they open up with a news item right and
it's like very it's like nhk this is the
day they do but they said the news very
kind of formal and then they go okay
we're here today with commentators so
and so and then they go back and forth
and talk about it so once you once now
this is something i even recommend if
you're new new new it's fine because
they're speaking in very
normal terms right just every now and
then you're gonna hear things that are
super high level but guess what it
doesn't matter what you listen to in the
beginning you're not going to understand
any of it anyway so just again so
j-u-r-i
judy is one yeah and the other one is
cozy up c-o-z
they also have a youtube channel so you
can get it on like a podcast app or a
youtube channel okay uh those are two
for that now either of them have
transcripts
not that i know i'm not that generous
okay i know that that's important i know
it's important for link right
unfortunately you can throw these onto a
happy scribe automatic transcription
service and it's kind of 90
okay all right that's very good the
thing about target how about correct and
think about these things sorry go ahead
no you're going to say do you have some
good podcasts for korean
i have an excellent one for korean
it's called
[Music]
now you're not going to find that one
english it means two o'clock date and
it's i think one of the longest running
uh korean radio shows in all of korea
uh i listen to it all the time and and
every year or so they'll change the
announcer
my opinion firmly is that the last
announcer was the best
but uh now it's two people
somehow we're gonna find these i'm gonna
put them in the description box i'm
gonna link i'll send you the links okay
um
let me see if there's anything uh let me
see let me just see quickly if i can
easily give you something that
identifies that one easier
uh but yeah that one that one's good
because it's two people uh talking and
they go rapid fire through topics right
and then what they'll do is they'll
introduce something that like a
housewife
in busan had a problem and then she they
so the topics changed
uh fresh enough so that if your korean
is uh intermediate level there might be
one particular thing where all of a
sudden you understand right and then the
next topic will come and you might
understand so i call that like this
random pocket of understanding and i
my korean significantly improved just
listening to that for 30 or 40 minutes
like as i was driving around
uh and once you get good you start being
like you start thinking oh wow i'm
actually enjoying the content you stop
thinking about oh i'm speaking korean
but what i get what i get from you and i
think the big lesson is
is your enthusiasm
your willingness to not understand your
willingness to be in a situation where
you can't quite say what you want to say
you don't quite understand everything
that's being said and you're happy
nevertheless and you just throw yourself
into it and in that you know that
approach is actually better than sitting
in a classroom trying to nail everything
down wanting to understand everything
and never getting beyond that class you
will learn
you learn so many things that the
teacher would never think to teach you
by listening to people talk
and i and if you want them uh steve i've
got i've got on here so what i do is i
get the podcast and then i put like a i
rename it so that it goes in order i
rename my like j
uh close parenthesis k close parenthesis
i have vietnamese uh i have russian
whatever i was learning for the moment
uh i would get it i have two or three
good german ones so i can i can give you
uh a good chinese one if you want one
how many languages are you working on
well i'm striving to be the next steve
kaufman
you got a few more years to go though so
i know well you know you really inspired
me because when i heard you were 75 and
you got 20 languages i thought well
i'm 48 right i've got
japanese korean some i'm fairly happy
with my chinese although i do need more
work right i started german right uh and
then once um
what's his name oh my gosh i shouldn't
forget this laoshu fifty-five thousand
yeah when he passed away right
uh i had i had a i had only a brief
interaction with him and it wasn't a
positive one fortunately but when he
passed away yeah i went up to his
channel and i watched more of his stuff
i found out how young he was and i saw
on his facebook he's doing these really
weird languages that i would never think
to learn right and then i thought that
guy had he had inspired so many people
yeah i thought what am i doing i'm just
sitting here not learning more languages
so that day
i booked tagalog which i really love
tagalog is amazing okay and uh and
vietnamese right
so
i mean
was amazing very humble guy
interested in
you know i didn't mean hmong
you know georgian you name it the guy
was and he had such a breadth of
interest in terms of languages another
guy who's doing that is richard simcott
i just saw him speaking uh estonian
and people i think you know we don't
have to be perfect in these languages
it's such a delight to discover a new
language to explore a new language
uh so good for you absolutely good for
you it really is you know
there's there's a
there's a subset in the japanese
community and i haven't seen it in the
korean community yet where they're
striving for perfection oh yeah or they
they put a lot of emphasis on do you
mean the japanese learning community
in the japanese learning community
um
and
it's never been my thing no you know i i
saw a ted talk once and it it really
summed up everything i've ever believed
about learning a language is that
language is a
tool not an art to master and
it's a tool for communicating it's also
a tool for discovering more about
different cultures different countries
and stuff like that it's not it's not
let's it's not synchronized diving at
the olympic games
right i mean we don't have to achieve
perfection that's what people want to do
that's fine too you know
well that's the thing it really is
especially nowadays if you want to
strive for perfection you can but my
question is what's your goal right is
that your goal or for me my goal is to
make friends in the country always yeah
like 100 so my goal in a new language is
uh to get to friends that don't speak
english right so that there's no
influence of the western mind on them
but but one more thing though is this by
learning say tagalog or korean or
whatever you're learning
you have a different perception
of those people like those people come
alive all of a sudden that's just not a
place on the globe or a map
those are real people now you have a bit
of a sense not maybe very deep yet but a
bit of a sense of those people that's
much more
alive than when you have never even
spoken or understood any of their
language
well if i can add to that and say
something slightly controversial
if you're living in america that's where
i live now so i see this you know we
don't really understand foreigners right
because we're america right and we're
number one and everyone speaks english
right right so
we're used to non-natives speaking
english in maybe not a perfect way right
so then maybe we think oh they're not so
smart but the minute you start speaking
their language you go you realize
they are really smart
just like we are there and it's a
controversial thing because that's a
weird thing to say but i'll give you an
example yeah i made a friend in korea
through hellotalk which is an amazing
app that i absolutely love right and
uh
when i first met her i just thought she
was kind of dumb like just not super
intelligent but it was my korean level
that needed to increase because once i
spoke more korean i found out she was
deep thinking you know she had deep
thoughts she was just a quiet person
you know i
this is the problem this is why people
are intimidated
about speaking another language because
they consider themselves intelligent in
their own language doesn't matter who
you are american chinese
whatever and you realize that when
you're speaking this foreign language
all of a sudden you're less intelligent
so you're dumb most adults don't like
that like kids don't care kids just want
to you know play with their friends but
an adult thinks well you know i'm an
educated person in my language whatever
it may be and now i'm going to speak
this other language and all of a sudden
i'm less or at least come across as less
educated that never bothered me but
there are people who are bothered by
that and i think we have to get beyond
that
and uh
just strive to communicate and not worry
about how you know whatever
imperfections there are
in how we use the language
i mean
that's fine it's extremely frustrating
when you're learning a new language
because you know how to say things
in english
and even for me you know i already knew
how to say things in japanese now i
can't say them in korean or i can't say
them in chinese so you get very
frustrated and this is a common thing
that i see over you know these 20 plus
years of teaching japanese and now
korean so i give this advice all the
time i say say what you can say right
not what you want to say
you know i'm following up to that i find
it frustrating when i can't say things
because i then reflect back on where i
was six months earlier
so well you're also a veteran you're a
veteran uh language learner so you're
aware and i'm aware of that too so i say
look at me all of a sudden i can say
things in persian or arabic
i can't quite nail it the way i would
like to i keep on forgetting things that
i know i know these words and i can't
find them when i'm speaking
but so what you know look at me now
versus six months earlier
so we have to give ourselves credit for
what we've done
yeah you have to recognize where you are
and i think you know we're like that
frog in a boiling you know pot that we
don't realize how hot it got right but
in a better way we don't know how good
we've got until we compare ourselves to
someone else or we start another
language but why don't we end it here
okay okay
and the main thing that you exude is
enthusiasm plus a lot of experience in
learning these languages and helping
others learn so thank you very much for
the conversation
all right hey thanks uh see you next
time okay have a good day steve okay
thank you bye-bye